[Music]
oh yeah
metropolis i can't wait to see what i
turn into here oh it's gonna be somebody
[Music]
dope
popping i'm freaking robbing and
why are we chasing a runaway train
we're in dc world doc and where there's
trouble
there's superheroes
i think the effects that we have
throughout the film are gonna be the
greatest thing about the whole movie
spice jam really takes advantage of all
of the cutting-edge filmmaking
technology
we've assembled such a tremendous team
because it's incredibly complex
we have all these textures and layers
and artistic complexities we really
wanted to make it film as handcrafted as
possible
while that process was to develop some
new tools to achieve that 2d aspect in
the 3d world we need a booth
a pick-me-up a secret weapon
we have to create every inch of this
insane eye-popping world
i look expensive it takes hundreds and
hundreds of artists to build these shots
let's get some birds in these seats how
big are these butts
a shot like that takes the better part
of a year you gotta be kidding me
oh you mad bro we're gonna see the
looney tunes up we've never
seen them before
there's gonna be so much going on in the
movie from one scene to the next
okay i got it new game plan
i've literally just been in awe of the
whole process
[Music]
you